welcome everybody
um thanks for shutting the door thank
you
um welcome
um to five design patterns for building
resilient applications
you'll be in one of three camps
Camp one uh you'll learn about some new
patterns that you can Implement in
c-sharp to build more resilient apps
came too
you might find some reaffirmation of
patterns that you already use to build
resilient apps
Camp 3 you'll hold your head and go oh
no
more on that later
my name is Derek Bingham my pronouns are
he him for those of you who don't know
me a bit of a this is my first time I've
ever spoken at an NDC conference
um it's not my first rodeo in terms of
speaking but my first NDC um so I'm
pretty excited to be here
um a bit of background I
I usually walk into a room and go hi I'm
Derek I'm a developer
um I've been writing software for for 20
years
um started off in in Java in the Java
stock move to.net about 10 years ago and
then for eight of those last 10 years
I've been building Cloud native
applications started off in Azure
um spent about four years building stuff
in Azure
um build a startup in Azure that was fun
didn't didn't work but at startups and
then for the last four years I then uh
joined AWS where I am now and I work as
a developer Advocate plenty of room up
the front
I don't I really don't buy it really
honestly
um so four years uh at AWS
now you may detect a a small accent I'm
originally from Ireland to very proud uh
from Belfast in Northern Ireland and
I've got green shoes my green connies
just to um point that out
um I currently live and have lived for a
very long time in Perth Western
Australia uh and hence I've got a great
suntan I've got the Irish Sun town so
that's me and and that's my side eye
look I like the side eye look
um
so I'm going to start with a quote I I
like starting with quotes
um so this one is failures are a given
and will eventually everything will
eventually fail over time this
particular quote comes from the CTO of
Amazon and when I first started giving
talks on resilience uh people you people
would shake their heads and go failure
is bad
um no failures are good failures are to
be embraced because like anything if you
don't if you build nobody's ever going
to build the perfect application and
specifically no when our applications
are distributed across different stacks
different networks there's a lot that
can go wrong but that's fine what we
have to do and the challenge that we
have is um software engineers and
software developers is to make sure that
when they do go wrong that we cater for
them
so today I'm going to show you hi
um by going through five patterns
and one practice to help you
build those modern apps in a more
resilient manner so I'm going to start
off with what is like the Baseline of of
all patterns is Thai bites so hopefully
who's who has never
use the timeout
thank you Ian I know you have uh who who
has uh is anybody not heard of any of
those patterns
so you've all heard of those patterns
excellent it's a really great start
um and who is currently
doing Chaos engineering
awesome so
um we'll get into chaos engineering at
the end uh chaos engineering is
something that when you're building
resilient applications it really goes
hand in hand with with these patterns
so today I'm going to build an
application
uh like all all good talks will take you
on a journey we'll take you on a journey
of this application and how um I improve
it over time by implementing these
patterns
warning
there are bad jokes ahead really really
bad jokes hence the group three oh so be
prepared I don't attend to offend
anybody in any way
um but they're really bad
um so warning
be prepared
so here we are we've got
the application I'll give people time to
read jokes
so what do computers eat for a snack
microchips
you'll have a punchline
a setup a punch line and a source and a
button
and if you hit tell me another
it'll go
once it's uh tell me another it'll hit
an API
and it'll get you another random joke
only two hard things in computer science
cash and validation naming things and
off by one errors
hey yes
um so every joke this is the the back
end service for that front end
and it has this is the Json that it's
dealing with
um and this is the actual class uh and
project that it is so I've got a little
react app here so the react app itself
um very simple it's got an app.js
and it's got a fixed joke component
inside the fed's Juke component again
very very simple it's got a um a bit of
a UI which I won't really show you it's
very simple and the the main function
inside this is populate joke data again
very simple async function it sends
requests out to an API so and it gets
black a joke in Json
deserializes it and sticks it in the UI
so that's that's the front end so what
about this API slash joke so this is
a.net controller
and the dotnet controller returns a list
of jokes
it implements the iGo client and I've
got one implementation of the ideal
Cloud interface uh it is here so what it
does it grabs the HTTP client it sends a
request out to a passed in third-party
joke API and then gets the result
serialized deserialize return to the
dotnet controller that I just shown
which then pushes it on to the um to the
client and displays The Marvelous jukes
the joke object itself is a setup
punchline and source and it's got access
there's a meat headers like any other
object
and that is it
so the net benefit is tell me another
microservice third-party Juke API result
or monkey's great Sports they are born
champions
and that that is the application
so if um so that was the code here's
some architecture so um PowerPoint
architecture my favorite so this is uh
react web application mixer request
the.net microservice which basically
acts as a proxy you know it's not doing
anything special so the proxy to the
third party joke API so then in this
particular example I'm using a
third-party Duke API but in the real
world it might be a database service it
might be another microservice it could
be anything it's just I'm identifying
that what happens when these things go
wrong
so the third party joke API returns a
response which then proxy back through
our friend.net microservice back to the
react web application
well that failures happen so what
happens if the third-party joke API
fails what happens if
it doesn't return
well the react web application has no
idea so it'll keep processing requests
proxy through the.net microservice which
is no idea that this third-party joke
API is broken
and a little weird
so it went for a a an indeterminate
amount of time depending on the language
that you're using so in uh C sharp
default timeline for HTTP client is a
thousand Millis ten thousand Millies ten
thousand Milli twitch you know is that
enough for your users who are waiting at
the same time probably not they probably
want a faster response but
that then uh that Cascades back to the
users and they'll see the spinning
spinning uh wheel
however
what happens if we have multiple clients
what happens if that multiple clients
start making requests for jokes because
that's fair that everybody wants a new
joke
um that goes to the.net microservice
which then again pushes it through the
third party joke API which is not
working it's broken it's failing it's
not returning responses so that request
will in fact weird as well
so what does that do
well those cascading errors then we'll
put the dotnet microservice underload so
what do you actually start getting is
cascading failures
and then the react web application well
they still don't know that everything is
broken and they will still start
requesting everything so your users are
going to be so
um unfulfilled because they don't have
any jokes to the day
I know it's bad it's bad
um so let's fix it so the first pattern
to fix this these sort of Errors is
called Thai bites and what we use this
as a as the Baseline
so here we are back in the
implementation of the Geo client so
luckily the HTTP client itself
um has a property called tiebout so
instead of using the default time for
HTTP client uh timeout we can override
that and set a time span from for five
seconds that way and we are making the
the request time determinant so we're
saying well I'm only waiting five
seconds
and so what effect is that going to have
so I'm refreshing the client let me get
a spinning wheel
when sometimes we'll get a joke
but if we refresh again and keep
refreshing eventually uh our.net service
is going to fill
so we'll keep going and trying to get
jokes trying to get jokes trying to get
jokes then all of a sudden we get this
spinny wheel
so what's what's happening well if we go
back into your.net microservice and do
the same action so we're requesting joke
requesting a joke
sometimes it'll start responding and
other times we'll get an unhandled
exception it's a timeout the timeout has
said five seconds is his went boom I'm
done
but we haven't handled that exception in
inside
um our controller
so that is doing nothing
um is something you should do is a
timeout because what you're doing is
constraining that try
and constraints are good but there's
more much much more
so who here has used Paulie
who here who's used pulleys thinks
Polly's flipping awesome
yes it is
um Paulie is a
um
a resiliency library for um c-sharp that
is
let's visit right developers really Izzy
we're not going to
um rebuild the wheel we're not going to
reinvent the wheel if there's a library
that does it for us yes please thank you
very much so Paulie is the.net Library
uh there's libraries for Java there's
libraries for typescript as well that
will do the same thing I.E right the
code that we don't have to so we can
build the resilient applications
so for the rest of the demo I'm going to
use poly
for those of you who haven't used poly
um
check it out
so
the next part is I'm actually going to
remove the default timeout so instead of
using the the default HTTP client
timeout I'm going to use poly so poly
you Define Poly as a policy so
everything in in poly is a policy hence
the name
um so I can write a timeout in poly by
calling the timeout async method giving
it a value again I'm doing five seconds
just to prove it is poorly there it is
uh once I've defined that the other
thing you have to do in poly is actually
execute the policy
so I'm now doing the executed sync and
then a sink Anonymous function inside it
which I'm going to define a cancellation
token
now what code do I have to put inside
this function well obviously the client
code that calls out to my third party
jig API
fix the indent and you need spaces
um and then next thing I Define this
cancellation token so CT is the
cancellation token that I'm defining and
I use it because I can then add it as a
argument to all the asynchronous calls
inside this function
so there's two uh there's the HTTP
client kit and then there's the reader
as string async
this gives me better granularity into
the timeout so this makes this better
than the original uh Timo
and if I run the application you'll see
that we although we get similar Behavior
so we'll refresh the client and
sometimes it'll work and sometimes it
may not because the third party joke API
is is going to fill
but when it when it doesn't we have
better control over those asynchronous
tasks inside the HTTP client calls
in this case it failed because it had a
task canceled exception
now I
just to just reiterate there are the two
CTS or cancellation tokens that can be
invoked and that will give you a bit of
control over your command over your
calls
now what I didn't mention is the
third-party Duke API itself is
completely random so the failures will
happen for a indeterminate amount of
time
um over a completely random time so
sometimes it'll work and sometimes it
won't and that's that's what we're
trying to prove
so we've had our timeouts we've
implemented timeouts the next one we
need to implement is uh graceful
degradation So currently our timeouts
you know we've defined a timeout value
we have better control over asynchronous
calls
um but we've got we've got great big
exceptions in in the controller which is
uh we need to handle those uh we need to
degrade gracefully hence the name of
pattern two graceful degradation so here
we're going to Define what's called a
fallback
so a fallback is something that will be
returned to the client if the third
party joke API is not working or
um is failing so how would we Implement
graceful degradation uh using poly
so to Define
um graceful degradation we first must
Define a fallback
so we Define a fallback again using
pulley
so we Define a policy and the policy
itself needs to return what the API is
going to return I.E a a list of jokes
and when must this fallback be invoked
well I'm going to handle exceptions you
don't have to be so as for both as this
you can be quite directed but exception
is good for this demo and then when that
when I that exception is handled
what you want to do what does the
fallback want to do well it's going to
return a list of jokes and it's going to
do that in an async method so all I
Define again a an async method with the
cancellation token and it's going to
return a list of jokes now
for this demo I'm just going to do a
single joke
um because you don't really don't want
any more
um but
for usually for fallbacks you define a
list of potentials and then choose a
random one
so with a joke you need a source a setup
and a um
a punch line set up and a source so I'll
Define the setup in the punch line in a
bit the source is something different so
I want to indicate to you and to my
users where this joke has come from so I
Define the source as fallback
once I've defined this function I then
need to tie it into my policy so my poly
policy so remember the exception that
invokes this fallback comes from the
timeout
so I need to wrap the two and I do this
using a policy wrap async call
and inside this I Define the policy so
that's the one that's calling that's
actually using the initial exception
and then uh make the policy wrap the the
initial executor
and that's it so the last thing to do is
another amazing joke
which is I am in a band
called 1023 megabytes
anyway we haven't had any gigs yet
anybody anybody oh drone we've got a
grown nice
yeah so that's that's our joke and
that's execute F5 this and and see how
we go
please ignore my errors this is a devil
um
so they're just warnings
so let's uh refresh the client first of
all
so what we're doing now and we're
retrying so all of a sudden we are in
fallback because we've um we've hit the
five second timeout and it's invoked the
fallback but if you hit tell me another
hopefully there we go we got we got a
udb jug even though we might not
um that came from the third party Duke
API which is recovered which is
fantastic our application is still
running even though the third day party
API has has went through failures
again from the controller if why don't
we have verbals have time because
they're not Wombles
um so this oh this is all coming from
the third party API which is all
recovered and so our fallback is
invoking uh and it's giving the API time
to recover
so that's it our fallback
generator full black rapid the policy
saying after five seconds there is an
exception the exception is handled and
then the fallback is is returned so our
application can can continue delighting
its users and hopefully they'll have
lots of jokes to keep them going through
the day
so that that is gracefully degrading
pattern three is is retries
so retries is
all about when I mentioned graceful
degradation I mentioned given the API
time to recover retries is the next
evolution of that we want to say okay
when I make a request to my third party
API or my my back-end service or
microservice or anything
um one request is not enough
um because maybe it needs time to
recover so let's let's try again
um and that's what a retry is try it
again
so to implement a a retry
I'm just going to refractor this General
fallback into a distill method just to
clean it up a bit uh and I'm digging all
the defaults so
enter and so the next thing I'm defining
is my retry policy so the retry policy
it itself again a a poly policy
and what I'm what I'm doing here I need
to handle uh again when to retry so
again I'm being quite verbose with this
and going with exception
um you don't necessarily have to that's
for sure and I'm calling the retry async
method within uh poly as a result and
given it a retry code so how many times
am I going to retry on exception
once I've defined that I then need to
put it in my wrapper so the wrapper
think of the wrapper is the order of
Precedence so what I'm doing is saying
well first one policy so do an initial
timeout then retry policy so retry five
times and then if both of those do not
work or Reason exception uh then it's
General fall back
so F5 that and let's see how that works
so what I'm expecting is longer longer
times the spinning wheel of depth as I
call it
um so although you need to be careful
about how much time you you let your
users wait
um and that's something that um you have
to Define I'm just using five seconds
and five retries as part of this demo
but just be very reticent and very aware
of what your users are experiencing when
you're defining your retry policy um
so there we are if we've retried five
times and we've got our fall back so
again the third party API is not working
but then we tell me another we got 10
types of people in the world those who
understand binary and those who don't
that's my particular favorite
um and then so then if we go to the um
back end
we're hitting we hit refresh so let's
retry
and we're a dollar monkeys joke again so
the third day party API is good
we hit it again
why did buildable Bargains always eat
his lunch at noon he was a creature of
Hobbit
come on
uh we will try again and you you'll
notice that although it's maybe waiting
a little bit longer we're always getting
results so implementing the retry
pattern
and then sometimes we ex we go beyond
our retry tips
and we'll get our fall back
and there we go so what's happening is
our
um our application is beginning to
handle these failures better
we've got rid of the exceptions we are
being quite specific in our timelines
and now we've added a retry
of five
and then finally always going to our
fallback we always have that fallback to
invoke so our users always get something
to look at or a joke to look at this is
good
so that is um retries
however like everything it is not the
end
there's many many
um challenges with the default retry
many challenges
the the first challenge well the
challenge I'm going to talk to and why
we need this pattern called exponential
Buck offs is this
so a react application is
um calling through to a.net microservice
and then we're retrying retrying five
times so we we first of all we try
and then we wait two seconds and we try
and then we wait two seconds and we'll
try
and what that's actually doing because
we remember our retries we're trying to
implement or retries to give our third
party API a chance to recover
but what we're actually doing is
hammering it even more
um so the third party API it's trying to
come up again and we're just retrying it
again and it's going oh
so it's not great
so exponential Buck off is all about
building on that idea or concept of
letting that third-party API recover
give it time give it time to do what it
needs to do to get better
so instead of having our next retry
after two seconds we increase the um the
retries exponentially
um so we wait four seconds until the
next one
and then it seconds until the next one
and then finally after 16 seconds
hopefully arbitrary numbers of course
hopefully the third party API has
recovered and can send us another
marvelous joke
so let's implement the exponential back
off
so it's basically a retry with a fancy
timer
and shock
so what we need to do is get rid of the
default retry code
um and
and wait and retry a sink so here we're
going how much duration between a single
retry
and how many retry attempts do we need
to make
and then we do some maths so we think
um a time span based on the number of
times that we've done times the Power of
Two
so what that's doing is we'll build an
exponential retry
and that's it
so simply by defining this wait and
retry async number of retries pass in
the retry attempt to a little math par
um you can build your own exponential
back off so let's see how that works
again what we'll see is as we retry uh
the time will go out
but we'll always get we should always
get that result even if it's a fallback
so you'll see we're spinning we're
spinning and there we go
why do you call it diver from Finland
nerdick very apt where we are today
thank you
um
and then we refresh again uh a poly sees
to any finish in the audience
[Music]
so this is taking some time so obviously
we're quite a long way down our retry
attempts
and we're going and we're going and
we're going retrying retrying
there we go and we're back to our um our
fallback
but when we retry game we've got our
great monkey joke uh back so our third
party API it's gone back and um our
retries have worked so refresher very
simple take your default retry policy
and add a wait and retry a sink to it
Define the number of times you want to
retry and the time span between those
retries which you can Define and
have using a mass of the power of
whatever
up to you again
always thinking about your users how
long do you want them to to wait for in
this case or how how long are you
willing to take that potential
Downstream effect of them winning
but there's more
there's always more
only five patterns today but there's a
lot more so
we've done retries we've defined that
retries well they're good but they're
not Korean because they don't give our
API a third party API in this case time
to come up again
so we add an exponential back off
as I said developers are lazy
everybody does a par too
so what happens
you get clustering so you're clustering
of your retries because
somebody is went to a talk seen some
crazy Irish man at the front do a retry
with an exponential back off and went oh
I just do my math part two let's do that
um what happens you do that enough
Services you get clustering so that is
again putting your services that you're
calling under under load because all the
retries are coming at the same time
um so it's not going to have about a
good day
so what we recommend and what you should
be using when you do a retry an
exponential back off is ADD Jitter so
Jitter is a way of adding a random time
to your retries
so that way they'll flatten off that
those retry curves and your service will
have at least three tries to handle
while it's trying to come up again
let's implement it so this is even
easier to implement than the exponential
back off because all what we're doing is
simply adding a time frame and in in um
C sharp that's really easy we've got
time span we go from Millis and then we
Define a random value of Millis so I'm
just going to do new random between zero
and a thousand Millis and that will
allow me to um have a a flam that retry
curve and add Jitter into my exponential
Buck off that's it nothing easy easy
peasy
so when again when you're doing retries
think go okay I probably need to add a
exponential back off here and then go
the next step and add Jitter three lines
of code
and your consuming services and the
people who do um look after them will
forever be your friend
within reason unless you tell them these
jokes then you're stuffed
okay
um pattern five so
there's been some similarities about
between pattern one and pattern four
pattern five is a little bit different
uh the circuit breaker
brings into
um thinking State so with the circuit
breaker
it has an awareness of the current state
of the third party API
so the idea being if it knows that the
third party API is not behaving or
um you know feeling
then it can jump in and service requests
instead
how does that look in our old friend the
PowerPoint architecture diagram well
like this
so we have our application proxyther.net
microservice to your third party joke
API which is filling randomly
and we'll keep requesting and requesting
and it's still failing so there's
nothing coming back
so what do we need to do in our
microservice we Implement a circuit
breaker
so what this is doing is completely
breaking any further requests between
the.net microservice and the third party
Juke API
again another method to let this
third-party joke API
um recover
but it's different because the.net
microservice needs needs to have an
awareness of its services calling and
instead of it so circuit breaker then
once is invoked he invoked for a number
of minutes
up to you arbitrary depending on your
requirements and how long you want to
give it
and then for those X number of minutes
the circuit breaker will return a
response which will be a fallback so our
list of fallbacks or something that will
keep your application running even
though the third party joke API is not
and that in essence is the circuit
breaker so that every subsequent request
if it comes through from the client if
it's in the the time window for the
circuit breaker the circuit breaker will
be invoked and it will return the
response
so let's let's code that up
so the first thing I need to do is
introduce a little bit State uh into
this controller so I'm going to abstract
this up to a wrapping up to a field uh
inside the controller
I'm defaulting everything apologies for
my coding style this is a demo sorry uh
and next I want to do is abstract all of
the um setting the policies I want to
abstract all those into a method
I want to move that method which is
called init policies I want to move that
method into the Constructor
so it's a very very rudimentary way of
introducing uh stated to this controller
um but it proves the point so you need
to Circuit you need stitch for circuit
breaker
so in init policies
I then go and Define the new circuit
breaker policies
so I'm going to have to Define two
things here first
the first thing is the actual um policy
itself
it's amazing to be imaginatively cold
circuit breaker
and it is a policy and it handles
what does it handle
you see a pattern
um emerging here
so it again handles exception and was it
due when
[Music]
um
the exception handles it actually calls
circuit breaker async
so the next stage is you know hi how
long do you want to
um
invoke this circuit breaker for so I'm
saying if you if the third party API
gives me five ex exceptions then invoke
the circuit breaker for one minute
that's the policy
but I also need a fallback because the
circuit breaker needs something to
return so I Define a circuit breaker
fallback
again this fallback is very similar to
the general fallback where I need an
innumerable or a list of jokes to return
but for this
um this presentation it's going to be
one
maybe maybe when I I do the presentation
another time I might actually think of a
list of jokes
I've got time
please give feedback
um so once the uh so the circuit breaker
fallback needs to be invoked and it's
invoked when a broken circuit exception
is called so the broken circuit
accession comes from the circuit breaker
policy
so you see how poly very very lovely
nicely puts all this together
the fallback async calls a numerable
joke
returns a nameable joke again async
function with a single joke inside it
which will be the fallback
and another reason I like Paulie is that
the pattern the patterns that you
program in are just makes sense or
elegant
um so
so the new joke this time
um is similar so it's got the three
Fields it's got the setup
it's got the punch line and it's got the
um the source
again I'll leave the best bit to the end
where I Define the new joke
and then the source this time is going
to be the circuit breaker fallback
so
once I've defined the joke that the
fallback is going to return
I then need to of course wrap it in my
policy wrapper so I set the order of
Precedence so I've got my general
and my retry I'm actually going to put
it in front between the policy and the
retry policy
and so the first thing I need to do I
need something I need to Define
um the actual fallback it's going to
Bubble Up
but I need something to invoke the
fallback which is the policy
and then I'll put my other
um sync my I need original policy and
then my retract
sorry my original policy so that that's
my my policy wrap so there think of it
bottom to top or a presence precedence
so and eventually I'll get my general
fallback so a joke
why did the developer
go broke
nope
nope well because they used up all their
cash
no okay
okay so F5 that
um
let's go
so let's refresh and I think this so
this time
um
I actually invoked I cheated for this
one because this is a lot a long time to
actually invoke so I'm going straight to
the circuit breaker fall back because
I've had five retries for the exception
exceptions in the fallback is there what
I'm now demonstrating is a minute It
Takes a Minute uh so I've defined this
time as a minute so every other request
that I'm doing is going straight to the
fallback it's really quick making the
applications responsive it's not waiting
for a timeline not waiting for anything
like that it's just going straight
um to the circuit breaker boom straight
straight back to the cloud so it
maintains a much more responsive feel
than you would get if you were using a
retry pattern
so we've got a quick overview uh and a
refresher so think about it exceptions
are live before in booking how many
minutes the circuit breaker is in force
um again up to you arbitrary for the
demo
uh then once the circuit breaker is in
force return the fallback so I mean it's
going past and hopefully uh still going
still being responsive still getting the
fallback
once I refresh it there you go how many
programs take a ticket change light bulb
none it's a hardware problem
true so now the third party joke apis
come back are um our fallback is gone
and now we're
um we can start requesting the the uh
the um third-party joke API and we've
got it's returning it may be slower but
it's returning inside the five
exceptions that were that we've set for
before the um the circuit breaker is
invoked
cool so that's five patterns and more
than five jokes
um the next practice is the practice
that I used
for the third party API so it it's
it failed randomly
um and I measured what happened
and I changed my application as a result
that's chaos engineering
or in other words chaos engineering is a
process of stressing the application
by creating events
observing observing how the system
responds and implementing improvements
um the key you break it
see what happens here fix it
chaos engineering simple that's it bye
it's not so chaotic is chaos engineering
implies chaotic chaos it's not there is
a very defined process
um and phase of chaos engineering I'll
describe these uh to finish this talk
off today
so you start in in chaos engineering
terms uh with a steady state so the
steady state is your your your
application running really happy serving
users
serving fantastic jokes and then all of
a sudden somebody says oh what about a
hypothesis what would happen if I
stopped the third party joke API
randomly for a minute
um let's see what the what happens there
that's the hypothesis
when you've got the hypothesis it's time
to run the experiment
so I ran the experiment in this is AWS
Fulton Jacobson simulator you don't have
to use this this is what I use I work
for AWS it's nice to use uh other chaos
engineering Frameworks chaos Simeon Army
chaos monkey whatever
but here I'm stopping my apis so my joke
API is all in five ec2 instances I'm
setting up an action to actually stop
them
so I call this action obviously stock
instances and I give it a really
descriptive name like we'll stop all API
instances
then I give it a type so fault injection
simulator has a number of types that you
can use this one's called stop instances
and then after a minute so I'm giving it
a minute and saying once that minute is
gone I can start the instances again
the next thing I need to do is actually
Define the targets so what
um ec2 instances are services or
whatever that I want to stop so I'm
using tags to define those those
instances
and then I can Define things like stop
conditions if I want to and I'll always
give you a warning because although it's
called default injection simulator it
will stop real things
you're warned so here are my API servers
that are running my third-party joke API
what I do know is run or start this
experiment hit start another warning
warning this is real stuff not
simulating
so that will start to initiate and
eventually start running so at the
minute it's initiating go back to me c2s
they're still running
all good
keep refreshing they're still running so
I then have to jump back into my
experiment
and a refresh and you'll see now it's
running
so I expect not my ec2s to come down and
there they are so they're beginning to
stop
and so what will happen now is those
ec2s will stop for a minute and then
start again
so once I've run that experiment I then
need to verify so I need to see what's
going on what's happened
um so I look at my observability
observability so my logs while my
application insights are doing uh and
I've verified what's happened
uh so in my case and this application my
my joke application I verified that uh
you know things were taking longer than
expected I was getting timeout
exceptions things like that I verified
and then once I verify
the next thing I need to do is improve
so what I'm showing now is after the
minute the ec2s would start start
running again and the third party Duke
API would start serving requests so I
can set this up on a schedule I could
set it up to run
um whenever uh unsuspecting individuals
uh are running don't do that in
production no no no no
um you can actually and if you're if
you're really high up the curve um you
can actually run false injection
simulators in in production uh just be
very
um careful about times you don't want to
run peak times you don't want to run it
um when you're if you've got an event on
or anything like that
um but they can be run in production
most people run them in in test
so now uh I've verified everything I
know what happens to my application it
breaks
um so now I don't improve it so how do
we improve it well we use the five
patterns that we've defined and that way
we build a more resilient application
as well as ec2s you can also run the
fault injection simulator across ecs's
so you can drain containers in ECS
elastic container service or you can
turn them in at node groups inside eks
elastic kubernetes service and do other
stuff like databases reboots failovers
which is very very handy if you're a
third-party joke API is actually a
database
so the other five patterns and one
practice of care for engineering I hope
all of you find your bucket either the
oh they're higher or the
thanks for listening if you have any
questions please you can either come
talk to me ask them now reach out on
Twitter always available
um please come ask I don't bite even
though they'll be sitting in the front
front row and uh thank you very much
no questions come on
we get to see a question all day
so we're going to start Okay so
we bought it in the chair
another name for it is of course social
engineering
um
I don't know if anyone has seen uh the
show Supernatural before
um it goes on a bit forever I've only
seen the first half of it but most
couple of Seasons it's basically all Sam
and Dean social engineering their way
into situations they'll rock up at the
door of some house wearing their suits
holding up their FBI badges acting like
they belong and so the people will let
them in and talk to them because they
think they're feds they're just social
engineering they're impersonating their
pretending to be something and
convincing people that they're supposed
to be there so in the picture up there
castile's holding an FBI badge and so
the people they're talking to think that
they're FBA agents
um so
I'm going to show hands um I'm pretty
trying to answer this question but how
many people here have seen me do a talk
before or know me in person at all I've
got what whoa fantastic okay how many of
you guys and you probably can't read
from the back but how many of you looked
at my badge
because my badge says Stephen Carter
while the slide where is it says Stephen
racecotter the agenda says Stephen
rayscato my badge also doesn't say
speaker
so you're all sitting there listening to
some guy standing at the front of the
room with the laptop and the clicker who
is pretending to be a speaker but my
badge doesn't say I'm a speaker
in after effect I borrowed this one from
someone whose name is very similar to me
thanks Steve
um which makes for a a fun demonstration
but the fact is I'm standing up here
pretending to be a speaker and you're
listening to me for the next hour and
you're unlikely to leave because it's
rude to leave in the middle of a talk
and now that I've said that you're
really not going to leave so have fun um
if you do need to go feel free to leave
I won't be offended just when I get that
out there but the point is that social
engineering is about
tricking people and convincing people
that you're supposed to be where you're
supposed to be or that you're supposed
to be given the information that you're
asking for that sort of thing
okay so who am I
am a PHP developer which I feel very
outnumbered in this place where there's
so many.net and other developers around
but PHP is awesome check it out I love
it
um I am a security consultant so I spend
my time cleaning infected website no
what am I saying that's an old job I
spend my time auditing code reading
people's code and looking for
vulnerabilities and then hacking into
their sites in order to prove if their
vulnerabilities there or not and help
them fix the vulnerabilities and keep
their sights more secure I write level
security in depth which is a Weekly
Newsletter about PHP and laravel
security so go sign up for that if you
do either of those things and laravel is
a PHP framework for those who don't know
and I used to have I used to clean
hacked WordPress websites
I'm doing well today
um which is a fun job um if you're
interested in security and malware and
that sort of thing then getting involved
in cleaning hacked Sciences it's quite
an interesting challenge
so back to security go back to social
engineering
it doesn't have to be
incredibly simple
here is a side of the hotel and you've
got back to your room and room service
are cleaning your room what do you do
well I got back to my room one day in
Vegas at Defcon which is the big hacker
conference and there's what 30 000
people in Vegas at the hacker conference
most of them hackers and social
Engineers people that like to push
boundaries break rules see what they can
get away with
I got to my room I loited around the
corridor while they were cleaning my
room when they were finished cleaning
they walked out looked at me and said oh
is this your room and held the door open
I walked straight into my room without
the key
kind of freaked me out a bit I had to
check my laptop my passport I didn't
wasn't I didn't trust the cleaners but
the fact that they were just letting
everyone into the room was a bit scary
especially since it's Defcon and they
let the staff know that hackers are in
town doing that sort of thing
another day another hotel my wife kids
were up in the room having dinner I got
back to the room late I didn't have the
key I walked up walked through the doors
up to the counter and said oh sorry I've
forgotten my key the lady behind the
desk immediately said which room number
was it I told her the number she wrote
me the key I walked into the room didn't
ask my name didn't look at my license I
didn't recognize her she wasn't there
when I checked in I just looked
trustworthy I walked in the front door
for crying out loud and she gave me the
key to the room I wanted the room the
key for
social engineering it doesn't have to be
fancy it doesn't have to be big and
flashy if you look like you know what
you're doing people are going to believe
that you're doing what you're supposed
to be doing
take for example these two
they rocked up at a zoo wearing these
things hi this vest ten dollars from
Kmart
you'll have this verse they've got a
clipboard
and they've got walkie-talkies and they
wandered around the zoo checked out all
the exhibits
they also went to an amusement park
right on all the rides again didn't pay
a single thing because they looked like
they knew what they were doing they were
wearing HyVee as they had radios
everyone just assumed they were where
they were supposed to be at the time
now Hovis isn't going to get you into
everything and I'm not quite sure what
these guys think they're doing are they
trying to hide trying to be seen who
knows
point is you know social engineering
um if you look like you know what you're
doing then people are going to ignore
you
so Twitter a couple of years ago
Joe Biden tweeted this
giving back to the community or Bitcoin
sent the address below will be sent back
doubled if you send 1000 I will send
back 2 000 to only doing this for 30
minutes
Bitcoin address
kind of looks dodgy but you know maybe
maybe it's a thing
musk also tweeted the same sort of thing
you know the same message I'm doubling
the amount Bitcoin us Etc now granted it
is mask who knows what's going on in his
head he might be legitimate from him but
it's the same address as the others so
it's a scam
Uber did the same thing as well in a
bunch of other accounts so again you've
got the same thing you've got the
address you've got the 30 minutes you've
also got the 10 million dollar limit on
there as well
and then a bunch of crypto exchanges
also were included in this one as well
Gemini coinbase binance and coindesk
and so you've got a bunch of Twitter
accounts most of them are verified and a
lot of them have a lot of followers you
know millions of people can see them all
encouraging people to send Bitcoin to
this address and they'll get Bitcoins
back
so it was a scam obviously these
accounts have been compromised and taken
over and they're social engineering
their followers into stealing Bitcoin
now a lot of I don't know I can't say a
lot many Bitcoin owners investors
whatever you want to call them aren't
Tech literate aren't security literate
they don't understand security and
Technology
they figured out how to buy and sell
Bitcoins and cryptocurrencies for many
reasons but they don't can't recognize a
scam and so they're going to see a tweet
like this
and they're going to assume greatness is
great I want more money I only have to
pay bills or I want this I want that
and they're going to send the
cryptocurrency to it also you'll notice
here you know we've got the 30 minutes
there so we're adding in urgency
which means that you see this tweet you
go oh great there's only 30 minutes left
um this screenshot was taken eight
minutes into it so now there's 22
minutes left I need to send my money
quickly likewise we've got the 10
million limit up here which means that
you see this you think oh great I really
need to send my money quickly otherwise
it's going to run out and I'm not going
to get my my Bitcoin my double Bitcoin
so there's social engineering in here
we've got the scarcity you've got the
urgency and you've got the
recognizability of the account that's
posting it the Uber Blue Tick there in
this example is social engineering the
followers who have cryptocurrency to
send their money in order to make more
money that's the theory that's the hook
that's what they want
um and actual fact this one apparently
scam didn't really make them very much
money granted it's 13 Bitcoin you've got
what some 260 000 at the moment in
current money
um but from what I've read apparently
this was a very small payoff in terms of
crypto scams I don't know too much about
crypto so I can't really talk about that
but the point is that it didn't seem to
to gather as much as they hoped it would
gather
which is interesting in itself
so what happened is Twitter themselves
working for social engineering attack
so
um what Twitter said in their press
release was that the social engineering
attack occurred on the 15th of July 2020
and it was a phone spear phishing attack
right so what that means is it was over
the phone
so someone called up like to support
help and if spearfishing attack is
targeted so it's not just a status
phishing attack where you just send like
emails out to everyone but you gather
your information and your research first
what's the difference between calling up
and going oh yeah hi I worked there and
I forgot my password can you give me the
password they're going to hang up on you
and call security but if you do your
research to figure out the name of the
tools you want to access the name of
their manager you know I'll be able to
work then you could call up and go hi my
name is Mark I'm currently on site of a
customer we've got a big launch of
middle that's going on my logins aren't
working I can't get to Tool named blah
my manager Bruce and your manager Bob
are good friends they always have a
favors can just help me out here the
person you're talking to is going to
want to help you
because you've laid the groundwork and
that you do sound believable you're
helping a customer and they've got a big
launch so there's the urgency there and
you know there's the favor in in terms
of the managers so the person you're
talking to wants to keep their manager
happy maybe they're going for a
promotion or something
and when they hear that their manager is
going to hit it they're helping you
solve the problem they're more likely to
help you and so they'd hand over the
credentials
now the interesting bit was
not everyone they targeted in their
initial attack had the access they
wanted but they just gathered more
information in the first attack then
they tried it again and their additional
targets here with what they needed to
get the um credentials of the employees
so once they had the credentials for the
internal tools then they were able to
log into the accounts take them over
post the tweets follow through with the
attack
now I love this line in the press
release
um where Twitter say here
the attack relied on a significant and
concerted attempt to mislead certain
employees and exploit human
vulnerabilities
so exploit human vulnerabilities that's
social engineering that's the problem
existing between the chair and the
keyboard or you know those chairs and
the screen up here you know I'm
exploiting in in the scenario ahead of
the budget starts so it's all about
exploiting the human the person that's
vulnerable in finding that weakness
rather than looking at some technical
vulnerability like SQL injection or
whatever
foreign
so how do we solve the problem and it's
a tricky one because it's a people
problem it's not simply a case of you
know writing more code you know add more
filters in place
and it comes down to like security
awareness training and building Security
in the systems and so
teaching your staff to recognize
phishing attacks teaching them to
recognize what a dodgy phone call sounds
like and who should have access to
things but also maybe adding the trolls
in place so that like the high profile
accounts like you know you must get Uber
and such cannot be accessed by the
normal staff maybe you need multiple
staff members to approve things and that
way if you're doing an attack on them
you need to convince multiple staff
members not just one staff member
but that comes down to you know your
tooling and your systems and you've got
to build them in such a way that makes
sense for your environment what the
access is needed
and it's a tricky one to solve because
it's the people problem it's a human
problem
so on the subject of cryptocurrency
one way to steal it of course is the
technical Avenue you could try breaking
to say coinbase or something but I
guarantee they spend a lot of money and
time on security so good luck trying to
break into there
a better option again is to go after the
human
I say hey we've got a pretty standard
interaction on Twitter this person here
murky Waters is um posting about a
problem they're having access in
coinbase
coinbase being a nice corporate citizen
is responding and saying you know reach
out to us will help blah blah blah the
usual
but that wasn't the only response they
got
they also got this person up here going
here talk to this person on Instagram
they can help you out
I bet you know what's going to happen
with that one there's also this response
as well this is all on the same tweet by
the way this person came in we have
another person on Instagram who can help
the username here is a quite interesting
hack key 360 what's that suggesting
um and that's they're I'm encouraging
you to not bother with coinback support
same Conway sport are useless got
another different personal Instagram
here and another one so there's one
tweet has those four people going talk
to these people on Instagram to get
their help
and as I said before the cryptocurrency
people aren't always Tech leader and
security literate so they're going to
see this and think oh this person can
help me I might reach out to them
I'm assuming that they're going to
Instagram off Twitter to make it harder
to trace and to track and to shut down
we've also got this one which I love
where um coinbase helpline responds
um and says then as a DM and will help
they're impersonating the real coinbase
support obviously they realized here
that the ccdn the official coinbase
account so they do a second tweet it's
identical but they're missing the CC's
they just forgot to delete the first one
so that's pretty funny
and then to add some more we've got some
more support gone based support the code
base help 22 here and here this bottom
one can we base official spot on caps
because I don't know it's official
um and I love this last line This is
brilliant beware of impersonators posing
as support we'll never DM first
it's like yeah this didn't know the fact
that they're an impersonator
but I'm guessing murky Waters has
probably got a whole pile of DMS from
people I'm claiming to help with this as
well these are just the ones we can see
that are public
so attacking the human vulnerability
they're the person that and needs help
and doesn't know any better on Twitter
now if you want to go after the big
crypto investors you've got to follow
the five-step plan and just a disclaimer
I don't do crypto I've never done this I
don't know if it works this is based
entirely off what I've read and learned
I've never done it the big disclaimer if
you do it yourself it's not my fault
right
just want to get that out there in case
someone forget anyway
um the five-step plan first up we need a
data breach we need to figure out who
crypto investors are
luckily we have Ledger Ledger is a
hardware crypto wallet manufacturer that
had a data breach two years ago
the data breach included email addresses
names phone numbers physical addresses
which means we have a list of email
addresses of people that we know have
cryptocurrency in some form
we can then look for those accounts on
exchanges like coinbase and such
we can match up those email addresses
from The Ledger data breach with
credential stuffing lists from other
data breaches to find valid passwords
that they've used elsewhere and then we
try to log into coinbase or the other
exchanges to see if the password and the
email let us in
in the case of coinbase if they let us
in we're going to see something like
this
on the left we have our SMS two-factor
roll screen on the right we've got the
authenticator app and you might also get
like a hardware authentication as well
if you get anything but the SMS two
Factor off there's no point trying with
that because you've got to physically
get access to their device or things
like that
but if we're looking at the SMS to
factor off
we've got the last two digits here
dremelon Ledger included
phone numbers
so you match up the phone number in the
ledge data breach with the uh the last
two digits here and that tells you the
phone number of the account you're
trying to break into
then it's just a simple matter of doing
a Sim swap which is not simple but it's
doable you could just um one method
would be to call up the carrier and try
and convince them that you're the
account holder you've got their name
you've got their address you've got
their phone number you've got their
email address you've got a password for
them you could probably find them up on
Facebook there's a good chance you'll
find their birthday because people post
about their birthday and they post about
their age so you've got their date of
birth
um you might find pictures of their own
pets they're usually security questions
security question answers
um so you get all the information you
can probably do a theme swap on their
account by convincing the phone carrier
that you're the person that you think
they're speaking to
apparently a different method they're
using for this is you're actually social
engineer the credentials for the manager
tablet of the people that run the phone
stores you run into the store steal the
tablet out of their head run out and in
the five to ten minutes it takes them to
deactivate the device you you physically
do the simple swap yourself on their
devices in the Management console with
the credentials that you stole from them
and the payoffs for these um you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars if not
millions of thousands of dollars
millions of dollars I mean
cryptocurrency and so you're going to go
through the risk of running into the
store to steal the tablet and setting
all that scenario up in order to make
the money because there's a large payoff
of course it's crypto the payoff
involves getting the crypto somewhere
else which can be tracked and then
getting it out somehow
I don't know I don't not a crypto person
all I know is it's really tricky to
actually do anything with crypto that
you steal if it's large enough
quantities and it gets reported quickly
so figure that one out on your own I
can't help you with that one sorry it's
not part of the talk
um so
again
in this problem solving this problem
user education
um like it would be really fascinating
to see if coinbase and a bunch of the
and all the other exchanges ran their
crypto users through mandatory security
awareness training every month how many
scams would fail because people are
actually aware of phishing attacks and
are thinking about it granted the users
are going to get sick of it because who
wants to do security awareness training
every single month and they're going to
find someone else that doesn't do it and
then they're not going to land security
so it's a hard problem
that's why exploiting the human
vulnerability is so easy
all right this guy
um this isn't crypto related yay
um this guy here Lithuanian man I can't
pronounce his name I'm sorry it's just
down here
um so he convinced Facebook and Google
to send him more than 120 million
dollars by selling them a couple of
bills
foreign
so what they did was they called up
Facebook in Google and spoke to them
many times to gather as much information
as they could they did a bunch of Recon
they sent them phishing emails as well
in order to obtain a lot of information
they spent two years Gathering all that
research
so they could make a phone call to these
companies saying can you please pay our
bill and then come Facebook and Google
said yeah sure we'll pay the bill right
now and they did they stole 120 million
dollars
because they asked nicely after doing a
bunch of research again all social
engineering what's the point in hacking
when you can just call up and ask
so I got this email about a month ago
um as a side note the uh the name up
there is I'm guessing because my name
used to be Steven Rez before I got
married and I'm guessing this guy
actually has my name wrong in his
address book but I know this guy I
haven't seen him in about 10 15 years
and so what I'm guessing happened here
is that his email address account has
been hacked and the hackers have sent
these emails out to everyone on his
address book hence the wrong name
but this guy is Tech illiterate he has
no idea about computers which means that
email looks real it looks like the sort
of thing he'd send me there's no context
whatsoever it's just a link to Google so
you know what's wrong with it but it
raises alarm Bells anyway because I
haven't spoken to the guy in what 10 15
years
um and if you hover over the link you'll
see that thing
um as opposed to the Google Google
account that's down there so yeah so you
see that thing when you hover over it so
that's the sort of thing you got to look
for
um it's hard to show the hover on the
screen that's sort of thing you want to
look for when you're receiving read
emails is you know where it's actually
going of course it's hard when you get
moneyless things and they've got tracker
URLs that go to big long things anyway
but yeah
so
um okay got this email from the guy um
check out this one so figured I'd have a
look where it's going as you can see it
bounces through a couple of places
before we get here
which is um what was the first thing
that you all noticed
just shout it out
really that's the first thing you
noticed
it's actually https it's got the cross
through because it's portswiger New York
um burp sweep
um the thing that I noticed apparently
um you're all about this than me
yeah I noticed CNBC news bit
and so this page is trying to is
pretending to be ABC News granted the
domain name makes no sense whatsoever
for ABC News
um the https is irrelevant in this
situation because of how I loaded the
page because I was running it through my
my tracker thing but the point is
they're trying to be ABC News
um but they've got this super clickbaity
title ABC News is not going to do that
and the whole featured in thing you're
not going to fill in ABC News so they'll
completely miss the point on this page
but it's trying to be ABC News it's
trying to be a legitimate page that an
Australian would see and believe if you
scroll down you're going to see photos
of celebrities and fake quotes then a
payment box at the bottom for a
supplements so you can go buy their
weight loss supplements
I threw it on a UK VPN got that thing
a little bit more believable from what
I've heard about mail online you might
actually see this sort of stuff on there
again the domain name is complete
rubbish
um but most people don't look at that
anyway but you're going to see mail
online the female section you go to see
the headline blah blah blah you might
actually believe this will fall for it
now keep in mind this all came from I'm
going to go that Google domain so if you
actually remember what you clicked on it
makes no sense whatsoever
but what they're trying to do here is
Trick you into buying the product
handing over your credit card details by
impersonating a site that you might
believe and trust
so they're building that trust in there
setting up that scenario
okay so who anyone here know about know
about PR guy 17
seeing a few reaction's cool so PR guys
17 for those who don't know
um is a Twitter account a left-wing
novel labor pro-labor commentator I
should say it popped up during um the
lockdowns and pandemic down here in
Victoria
um and the right wing media in writing
commentators are pretty upset by power
guy 17 because he's anonymous and they
don't know who he is and he's been
annoying them because he has such good
takes the point is they're trying to
unmasked him and so they've done various
legal things to try and get information
and Twitter handed over an email address
and IP addresses for piago 17.
um and they said the person running a
thing this um other yemi can pronounce
his name again sorry he um he said that
he's given those details to a cyber
security expert a couple of days later
PR guy 17 receives this email
so it's all very interesting we check
the subject at the top and you've got
strictly confidential PR guy 17 letter
of demand and confidentiality agreement
reference number so it's trying to make
it look really really official and legal
and encourage him to open the link and
you've got it's really confidential
again a lot of legal jargon you've got
the URL and the password you know the
legal details about the law firm the
attachment at the bottom
it's trying very very hard to get this
guy to open up the docx file
but he didn't click it which is a good
thing um because you can imagine what's
in there the other thing to remember is
because there's a password on the
document virus scanners can't read it
so you've got malicious scripts uh
macros anything else running the docx
the virus characters can't pick it up
because if virus scanners could read the
unencrypted version of the file what's
the point of the password
so that's how you slip viruses and
malware through virus scans and doc
files and they're trying to socially
engineer PR guy 17 into opening that I
generally to hack his computer because
they're having no luck figuring out who
he is
um it's all pretty obvious who it came
from the timing is pretty clear the fact
it's all themed around illegal thing is
pretty clear also the fact that the only
people that have that email address are
Twitter and the people trying to figure
out who they are so he's used the burner
email address
so you know again it's a pretty blatant
phishing attempt
um pretty interesting number curious to
see where it goes because I know some of
the news sites
um media are trying to figure out you
know what the lawyer is they could be
referring to because none of the lawyer
details actually make sense like the
phone number doesn't work etc
so anyway
okay
on to a different phishing scam
um you can probably guess this one's
crypto given the amount of money it's I
just thought this one was quite
fascinating
so this person received multiple
notifications on their Apple device
about fail you know failed logins and
failed pins and that sort of thing so a
bunch of different security alerts so
they were on security alert they're
worried about their security of their
device
then they received a call from who they
thought was Apple the phone said it was
Apple so I thought it was Apple
and the apple called them and said you
know where am I trying to secure your
device
um you know we're going to send you a
one-time pin give us the pin so they
thought they were talking to Apple they
handed over the PIN
which allowed the hackers to drain their
crypto wallet
all from giving over the pin or the
Apple device
so what's going on here is the crypto
wallet they use on the phone backs up
its keys to the iCloud
which means that all the hackers have to
do is get access to the iCloud backup so
they can get into the crypto account in
order to steal the coin
and so it's quite fascinating that's
just some more details this person put
up about it but it's fascinating they
laid the scene so the attack is
targeting this person
sent through in the security warnings
and they set out that scenario so the
person is thinking about security so
that when they called up to talk about
security from Apple the person was
believing that they were talking about
that that there was something important
going on that they had to pay attention
that it was really Apple because they
thought there was a security risk which
there was but they didn't realize they
were talking to the hackers not Apple
themselves
foreign
physical security
phone skimmers no offense cut skimmers
what am I saying
this one's pretty obvious
looking at a side-by-side photo the one
on the left of course is the skimmer the
one on the right isn't but if you didn't
have the one on the right are you going
to notice that thing sticking out
you know you don't know what these
devices look like every single ATM and
card reader is different so how do you
know what is the skimmer and what is it
it's only by looking at the comparison
like that so I'm pointing it out that
you realize that it shouldn't be there
what's the next one
where's the skimmer here
I heard someone say it before
the other thing yeah
yeah the other thing up here is the
skimmer it perfectly you know that's
where the card goes in anyway but it's
so hard to see but the um the other
thing actually goes over the arrow
um and if there were designing this
thing properly the arrows would be below
it not under the yellow thing
so um if you know what you're looking
for that one's obvious but you're not
really going to pay much attention and
it's recessed in rather than sticking
out so it's a lot harder to see as well
so what about these things have you seen
these things before
see that the face plate
um so the skimmer here on the right hops
over the one on the left it looks
basically identical it's just slightly
thicker and fatter you're not really
going to notice the difference unless
you have good working knowledge of these
things and know what to expect on them
so again it's a that's a tricky one to
find I think also because it covers the
entire device as well the usual wiggle
trick might not reveal it as much
and of course this next skimmer
um have fun finding this one it's a
really hard one
that's funny
oh yeah so not really social engineering
but kind of hard I thought it was
interesting this one this person has
a photo of possibly their keys I hope
it's not their keys
um talking about their address and what
time they normally get home during the
day which means that if you want to
break into their house at this address
go before 5 PM
and if that's their keys and you know
how to pick locks or make your own Keys
then you've got the keys to get into the
house even if you don't you probably
could pick it anyway and they've told
you they've got a safe so what's in the
safe
you know if you're interested they might
have something valuable
break into the house with plenty of time
to pick into the safe
go for it
so yeah um I guess it's the human
vulnerability in terms of the
information they're leaking about about
the house and when they're home
okay so I've got a video here of um is
it kind of a play note called if you
hear of Vishing which is phone fishing
um but it's fascinating to watch
they're gonna happen using social
engineering which is essentially hacking
without any code they just use a phone
and an internet connection you want to
do a sample Vision call what's fishing
phishing is voice solicitation and
basically um what you do is you use the
phone to extract information or data
points that can be used in a later
attack let's do it when you who are you
going to call maybe I'll call your cell
phone provider and see if I can get them
to give me your email address I I bet
they're good I bet they have my back but
yes go go for it I'm gonna spoof from
your number so it's gonna look like it's
calling from you okay
[Music]
hi I'm actually I'm so sorry can you
hear me okay I my baby I'm sorry my my
husband's like we're about to apply for
a loan and we just had a baby and he's
like get this done by today so I'm so
sorry I can't um call you back
I'm trying to log into our account for
uses information and I can't remember
what email address we use to log the
account the baby's crying and
um can you help me
[Music]
awesome in just 30 seconds gmail.com
Jessica gets access to my personal email
address now if I needed to um add our
order daughter on her account so she
could call in and make changes how would
I need to go about doing that you would
have to send me a secure pin through a
text message yeah well the thing is I
don't think I'll be able to receive a
text message if I'm on the phone
oh I'm not on there either
so I thought when we got married
um he added me to the account Jess uses
my girlfriend's name and a fake Social
Security number five one two seven to
set up her own personal access to my
account wait I'm sorry so there's no
password on my account right now can I
set that up she even gets the support
person to change my password thank you
so much for your help today so she just
basically blocked me out of my own
account I'll get her fed up all right
thank you
there we go
it's that simple apparently all you need
is a baby
we need to baby crying
yeah
so she set up the scenario with the baby
crying and the urgency telling the rep
that she had to do it then she couldn't
call back later so the rep is
conditioned to want to help her
and then when we get to the the part
where you know she discovers she's not
on the account the rep is trying to be
helpful and doesn't want her to go in
new talk to her husband and get
permission all that rubbish so she just
does it for her to be helpful because
she believes she's trustworthy
so yeah it's fascinating so I've got one
more video
this one's fun
um so I'll just preface it so a couple
um we had an Apec here uh whenever it
was in Sydney I think it was Sydney a
little while ago and um the Chaser team
decided to see how good the security was
because that's what they do oh there we
go please work
follows they swing on apex security the
biggest lockdown operation the country's
ever seen and yet there were holes in
the security wide enough to drive three
trucks two motorcycles and four secret
service guards through top effort blokes
uh let's have a look now how it all
unfolded talk us through it okay well
Asana likes to travel in style right so
we made a do-it-yourself motorcade
cunningly disguised with this Canadian
flag oh yeah tomato day Trojan Horse
yeah but there are a few hints we were
fakes like our official code SFI
yeah I don't think motorcades have had
Runners since JFK especially not ones
with handicam
rolling nothing was going to stop us
except I we got a red light
yeah let him throw but yeah of course
don't keep us arm away you just watch
this guy here he stops the traffic and
then waves us through
that is amazing no questions asked but
hold on we roll right up to what they
call the Ring Of Steel there it is and
didn't security jump on us we stopping
oh you're fine
not too much checking at that checkpoint
yeah so look we were just walking on
down right on down to the red zone now
that is the real no-go Zone but I tell
you what it's pretty relaxed in there
look at this guy cop he was back to us I
don't know what he's looking at yeah
yeah
now you know the media said we got past
a second checkpoint but it wasn't really
like a checkpoint it was more like a
guard of Honor
not too fast are they yeah now look by
this stage it's become pretty bloody
obvious the cops weren't going to stop
us so we decided to stop ourselves sorry
I'm sorry I'm gonna have to turn this
around we're going to go back
okay now at this stage we've got much
further than we ever inspected I think
that's fair to say and all of a sudden
we're trying to turn around a motorcade
right in front of George W Bush's Hotel
Chaz I was a bit worried yeah but as for
the cops well they weren't so worried
we'll just go back this way okay okay
turn around turn around yours thank you
very much
thank you officers good work
great work well they did say the road
was ours my house to do whatever we like
apparently so look we've been in that
car for ages so we thought we might
stretch our legs a little okay let's
walk
yeah all right let's go
suspicious
obviously Julian Morrow
okay CRP liaison okay so here I am Osama
Bin Laden saying 10 meters away from
Bush's Hotel so what do they do they
arrest the other guy
[Applause]
oh no hang on oh there's some other guys
coming to arrest you now no they're for
me as well
you know what can you say to that
so you know the cops weren't looking for
a fake motorcade
the cops obviously figured someone else
was validating and you're checking what
was coming in and so they just let them
through because they looked like they
were in the right place
in the right part they weren't paying
any attention to it
again social engineering being in the
right place sorry being someone where
everyone thinks you're in the right
place I should say and convincing them
that you're supposed to be there so they
don't pay any attention to you
whatsoever
all right so I want to finish on this
one
and this is why a lot of people hate
security people
there's a lot of company companies and
places will do
um like fake fishing tests to see who's
paying attention and then throw
those people who have failed them
through you know security awareness
training but doing one of these tests
where you've got a financial incentive
like you know seven and a half thousand
dollars for the people that are
struggling with money and bills
unethical it's mean and the people
aren't going to learning from that I
mean this person isn't going to learn
about security awareness and fishing
detecting fishing from this experience
they're going to hate the security team
and they're going to hate the the whole
security process around it and the fact
they have to fit through the boring
security awareness training and so yes
granted that's the sort of thing that a
fisher would do if you were doing a
legitimate attack to get this person you
would of course send that email but if
it's part of your security training and
awareness it's it's not a good idea
it's unethical it's just going to leave
a bad taste in everyone's mouth and
they're not going to learn anything so
you need to go about security training
in a different way a way that actually
educates and teaches people
um and that's actually apparently I've
finished really really early for some
reason I must talk fast
um thank you for coming are there any
questions or anything
cool hey oh question yep
I think there's a microphone if only
goes on the recording if you use that
one
laughs
once your email has been compromised and
it's in one of those leaks and they've
got it as well as your phone number and
your address and your date of birth and
then you get you know these phone calls
and you know from unknown numbers
um you know So eventually what I did was
I kind of you know made that email
address an alias you know which then
gets put into the junk straight away
yeah and started using another email
uh but I I turned on silence unknown
callers which is problematic when I
actually want to receive a phone call
from an unknown caller yeah
what can I do if anything have I done
the right thing
um well out of all the things you listed
the only one you can't change is your
date of birth
um so yeah changing your email address
changing your phone number
um if it starts getting targeted
um
yeah I mean there's not much else you
can do apart from just be aware of
potential scams and you know anything
that comes in look at it and think you
know is this a scam or is this
legitimate
um yeah
um in terms of keeping like your account
secure that's where having different
passwords comes in
um and it's recommended for things like
crypto and such that you actually use
different email addresses for your
account so that if you've got your
account breached over here well then
it's not the same email address that
you're using on the side here even
though you've got different passwords
having a different email address as well
makes it even harder for someone to try
and Target your account
um so certainly started using uh hide my
email yep so whenever I go out to a pub
or anything like that I'm always going
to be using that even when I'm doing
online shopping same sort of thing yeah
um so it just seems to be a fair bit of
effort so that when I wake up in the
morning I don't have 37 phone calls and
150 spam emails yeah yeah it is it is
definitely a bit of effort yeah
um all right thank you that's okay yeah
that's I guess that's the problem with
this sort of thing is that once the
information's out there you can't do
much about it
um except for manage it or change the
details you can change and accept the
fact that
anything that goes to the old email is
potentially compromised yeah it's a
tricky problem
it's why it's um still such a big thing
or any other questions
yep go for it
well I've got the expert in the room
not only for myself but say for my kids
and and wife when we get these phone
calls from people we don't know
um how should we answer them because at
the moment on my voicemail says hello
you're speaking to Michael Jones please
leave a message other people you just
don't get anything which I think is a
bit rude but maybe that's what you need
to do can you give us some pointers
please
I don't know I mean
I guess that's I don't know I I honestly
don't know
um
it is a tricky one if you want people to
be able to call your number and know
that they've reached you then you've got
to put your name in it um and then it
just I guess you know you just don't
trust the phone calling what's what's
quite common and what a lot of
businesses are actually waking up to is
when they call people from for reasons
where you say to them is there a number
I can call you back
um and so you physically call back the
company based on the information you
find on their website rather than
talking to them on an inbound call and
so then inbound calls you basically
screen and don't you don't provide any
information over those
um because you sometimes get the
companies that want to you know verify
who you are when they've called you
which is just complete rubbish
um and they get upset with you that one
um but you know it's it's a tricky
problem and you can try to change you
know you can change your phone number
and such but then if the new one gets
out then you've still got the same same
issue yeah
foreign
[Music]
yeah exactly you can't really stop them
and they're always very cagey about
where they got your phone number from
um so so when they call you they're
trying to get detailed out of you
usually
yeah
yeah like
um yeah probably if they can convince
you that they're who they're claiming to
be yeah
I think in those situations you'd
probably just want to you know get their
number and say I'll call you back and
then call them
um rather than keep the the incoming
call going on yeah
oh yes yes
[Music]
hmm
well yeah I mean if I can give and see
the girl if I can convince you to go to
a fake company website that has a fake
phone number and it's quite an extensive
attack but if you're if they're
specifically targeting you or they've
set up the
stuff then yeah they could do it yeah
it's it's a tricky problem
s
[Music]
yeah it's it's um I guess there's still
a hanging fruit scenario if um if you
make it look like a scam and those who
know how to detect scams don't respond
to it then you have to deal with less
people that are going to figure out that
it's a scam the further they get through
is the theory that I've heard
especially like the email ones where
they're wanting you know to
to get your bank details or whatever the
new transfer money around countries and
all that nonsense and yes if they make
it so that only those who respond are
actually likely to believe it then they
have to put less evidence because
there's a manual process involved in it
go
oh thank you all